>>> AND A CLOSER THAN EXPECTED
SENATE RACE IN OHIO HEATING UP
OVERNIGHT.
DEMOCRAT TIM RYAN AND REPUBLICAN
J.D. VANCE FACED OFF IN THEIR
FIRST DEBATE.
SOMETHING TO SEE.
WITH ME NOW IS CNN'S OMAR
JIMENEZ.
SOME DEBATE THERE.
>> YEAH.
SOMETHING TO SEE TO SAY THE
LEAST.
BY FAR THE MOST CONTENTIOUS
DEBATE SEEN THIS MIDTERM CYCLE.
J.D. VANCE AND TIM RYAN TALKING
PAST EACH OTHER, AT EACH OTHER.
MODERATORS TRYING TO JUMP IN.
VANCE DESCRIBING, COMPARING RYAN
TO A TODDLER AT ONE POINT.
RYAN SAYING VANCE IS NOT
STICKING UP FOR HIMSELF WHEN
TRUMP'S ADVANCERS WERE KISSING
HIS ASS FOR SUPPORT IS INDYK
TIFB OF THE TYPE OF SENATOR HE'S
GOING TO BE.
>> Reporter: A NAIL-BITER SENATE
RACE HEATING UP IN OHIO.
>> VERY CLOSE TO HALLOWEEN AND
TIM RYAN HAS PUT ON A COSTUME
PRETENDING TO BE A REASONABLE
MODERATE.
>> I'M FROM OHIO.
I DON'T KISS ANYONE'S ASS.
OHIO NEEDS AN ASS KICKER, NOT AN
ASS KISSER.
>> Reporter: A CLOSER THAN
EXPECTED CONTEST THAT COULD
DETERMINE THE POWER IN THE
SENATE.
ABORTION, RYAN PLANNED TO CODIFY
ROE V. WADE.
>> MODERATION ON THIS ISSUE.
EXTREME POSITION.
J.D., YOU CALL RAPE
INCONVENIENT.
RIGHT?
THAT'S RAPE -- RAPE IS NOT
INCONVENIENT.
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT TRAGEDY, AND
HE THINKS THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
OHIO STATE LAW, WHICH SAYS IF
YOU RAPE OR INCEST, A PERSON WHO
IS INCEST, YOU SHOULD BE FORCED
TO HAVE THE BABY.
>> Reporter: VANCE SAYS HE'S NOT
AS EXTREME ON THE ISSUE AS RYAN
CLAIMS.
>> I AM PRO-LIFE.
ALWAYS BEEN PRO-LIFE.
MY VIEW ON THIS IS SPEAKING OHIO
IS GOING TO HAVE DIFFERENT
ABORTION LAWS THAN CALIFORNIA
AND TEXAS AND I THINK OHIO
SHOULD HAVE THAT RIGHT, BUT SOME
MINIMUM NATIONAL STANDARD IS
TOTALLY FINE WITH ME.
>> Reporter: THEN THE ABORTION
ISSUE TOOK A HEATED TURN AND
VANCE BROUGHT UP A 10-YEAR-OLD
GIRL'S RAPE CASE.
THAT GIRL TRAVELED TO INDIANA
FOR AN ABORTION AFTER ROE V.
WADE WAS OVERTURNED AND IN
OHIO-BANNED ABORTIONS AS EARLY
AS SIX WEEKS IN A PREGNANCY.
>> I'VE SAID REPEATEDLY ON THE
RECORD THAT THAT GIRL SHOULD BE
ABLE TO GET AN ABORTION IF SHE
AND HER FAMILY SO CHOOSE TO DO
SO.
THE THING THEY NEVER MENTIONED
THAT POOR GIRL WAS RAPED BY AN
ILLEGAL ALIEN, NEVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN IN THIS STATE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
IF YOU HAD DONE YOUR JOB HE
WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN RAPED IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
>> VANCE WENT ON OFFENSE TO
PAINT RYAN AS TOEING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LINE DESPITE
FORM PRESIDENT TRUMP TOEING THE
LINE TWICE.
>> HE TALKS ABOUT WANTING TO BE
BIPARTISAN AND GET THINGS DONE.
TIM, YOU'VE BEEN IN CONGRESS 20
YEARS AND THE BORDER PROBLEM HAS
GOTTEN WORSE AND WORSE AND
WORSE.
>> Reporter: RYAN THEN ALLEGING
THE FORMER VENTURE CAPITALIST
DEPENDED ON FOREIGN VOTERS.
>> HE HAS BUSINESSES IN OHIO
THAT ACTUALLY HIRE FOREIGN
WORKERS.
DO YOU THINK WE'RE STUPID, J.D.?
AND WE'RE NOT.
I'M JUST TELLING YOU THAT YOU
ARE -- YOU'RE FROM SILICON
VALLEY.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE IN OHIO.
>> Reporter: CLAIMING A NEW WAVE
OF YOUNGER LEADERSHIP IS NEEDED
IN WASHINGTON.
>> DO YOU WANT PRESIDENT BIDEN
TO RUN AGAIN IN 2024?
>> NO.
I'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR.
I'D LIKE TO SEE A GENERATIONAL
CHANGE.
MITCH McCONNELL, DONALD TRUMP,
THE PRESIDENT, EVERYBODY, LIKE,
WE NEED A NEW GENERATION OF
LEADERSHIP.
>> Reporter: VANCE AND RYAN ALSO
SPARRED OVER THE THREAT OF MAGA
REPUBLICANS.
>> ARE WE HAVING A GOOD TIME?
GREAT TO HAVE THE PRESIDENT BACK
IN OHIO.
>> Reporter: VANCE REPEATED
TRUMP SUPPORT THROUGHOUT HIS
SENATE RACE AND RALLIED WITH
HIM.
>> I WANT PEOPLE IN OHIO TO
UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS THE CROWD J.D. IS
RUNNING AROUND WITH.
THE ELECTION DENIERS.
THE EXTREMISTS.
HE'S RUNNING WITH AN EXTREME --
VERY, VERY DANGEROUS.
>> I FIND IT INTERESTING HOW
PRE-OCCUPIED YOU ARE WITH THIS
AT A TIME PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
GROCERY, CAN'T AFFORD TO WALK
DOWN THE STREET SAFELY.
LET'S FOCUS ON THE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES RIGHT NOW, TIM.
>> Reporter: THIS IS A STATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP CARRIED TWICE BY
ABOUT EIGHT POINTS AND POLLS
KNOW SHUE NO CLEAR LEADER.
SIGNIFICANT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY REPUBLICANS
SPENT ON ADS.
OVER $90 MILLION TO THIS POINT
AND DEMOCRATS AROUND $30
MILLION.
ONLY SURPASSED IN TOTAL SPENDING
BY RACES IN WISCONSIN,
PENNSYLVANIA, ARIZONA AND
GEORGIA.
ALL PLACES WHERE TURNS OUT
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE CLOSE.
>> LOOK, TIM RYAN AND ALLIES
SAYING THE DEMOCRATS, LOOK AT
US.
WE'RE HERE.
REALLY CLOSE.
COME HELP US OUT.
DON'T MAKE IT A MONEY THING IF
THAT'S WHAT WE LOSE HERE FOR IN
OHIO.
THANK YOU FOR SHOWING US WHAT
HAPPENED LAST NIGHT.
>> JOINING ME TO DISCUSS THIS IS
OUR PANEL.
A LOT OF KISSING.
A LOT OF OTHER THINGS GOING ON
IN THAT DEBATE LAST NIGHT.
BUT A REALLY FEISTY SHOWING FOR
BOTH OF THEM.
BUT FOR PARTICULARLY I THINK TIM
RYAN WHO IS KIND OF -- HE'S
DUKING IT OUT AND HE WOULD SAY
REALLY ALL ON HIS OWN TO TRY TO
FLIP THIS SEAT THAT DEMOCRATS
BASICALLY SAY OHIO IS LIKE KIND
OF GONE.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, LISTEN, ALL OF
THE SORT PROGNOSTICATORS SAY
THIS IS A LEAN R STATE.
WE HAVE SEEN IN PREVIOUS
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS IT'S GONE
HEAVILY FOR TRUMP IN THE LAST
TWO CYCLES AND SO THAT'S WHY
DEMOCRATS AREN'T REALLY PUTTING
MUCH MONEY INTO IT.
TIM RYAN HAS HIS OWN SOMETHING.
SOMETHING LIKE $25 MILLION
PUTTING IT ON THE AIR BUT
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO FIGURE OUT IF
THIS IS A RACE THEY WANT TO PUT
EXTRA MONEY INTO BECAUSE THEY'VE
GOT A STATE THAT THEY COULD
POSSIBLY FLIP.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY AN OPEN SEAT BUT
WE'LL SEE.
TIM RYAN DOING MUCH BETTER THAN
I THINK PEOPLE THOUGHT HE WOULD.
>> ONE THING I HEAR PRETTY
CONSISTENTLY FROM DEMOCRATS EVEN
THE ONES WHO DON'T NECESSARILY
THINK IT IS WINNABLE THINK HE IS
RUNNING A GREAT CAMPAIGN.
PART IS WHAT HE IS DOING IN THE
CLIP.
DISTANCING HIMSELF FROM NATIONAL
DEMOCRATS.
>> TIM RYAN AND JOE BIDEN HAVE
CONSPIRED TOGETHER TO REJECT
EVERY BORDER WALL FUNDING
PROPOSAL, TO REJECT EVERY
PROPOSAL TO CUT OFF THE AMNESTY,
TO REJECT EVERY PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY SECURE OUR BORDER
AND STOP THE FLOW OF THESE
ILLEGAL --
>> KAMALA HARRIS IS ABSOLUTELY
WRONG ON THAT.
IT'S NOT -- WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO.
>> SO WILL THAT WORK?
>> I MEAN, TIM RYAN IS MAKING A
PRETTY GOOD RUN AT IT AS YOU
SAID.
HE HAS MANAGED IN THIS CAMPAIGN
TO DO SOMETHING WHICH IS
RELATIVELY DIFFICULT FOR MEMBERS
OF EITHER POLITICAL PARTY WHICH
IS TO DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM THE
PARTY BRAND IN THIS CASE FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S PART OF
THE REASON WHY HE IS STILL
HOLDING HIS OWN IN WHAT IS
OTHERWISE A PRETTY DIFFICULT
STATE FOR DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THE VALUE JUDGMENT THAT
PARTY OFFICIALS AND STRATEGISTS
HAVE HAD TO MAKE IS, THIS IS
REALLY A REACH.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FUNDAMENTALS
OF THE STATE, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF THE RACE, AND
GIVEN THE MATH THEY'RE FACING
THEY NEED TO DOUBLE DOWN I THINK
A LOT WOULD SAY IN THE PLACES
WHERE THEY HAVE MORE OF A CHANCE
TO PICK UP A SEAT AND SO THIS
WOULD BE GREAT IF THEY COULD GET
THE ROB PORTMAN SEAT, HE IS
RETIRING AND THEY WOULD LOVE IT
BUT I THINK THE REASON WHY WE'RE
SEEING THIS SORT OF LACK OF
ENGAGEMENT RELATIVELY SPEAKING
IS BECAUSE IT IS REALLY A REACH
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
REALLY DISTINGUISH HIMSELF FROM
THE REST OF HIS PARTY IN A LOT
OF WAYS.
>> TO BUILD ON JULIE'S POINT,
DEMOCRATS ARE MOST FOCUSED ON
KEEPING THE SEATS THAT THEY
ALREADY HAVE IN A REALLY TOUGH
ELECTION YEAR.
PUTTING MONEY INTO STATES LIKE
GEORGIA WHERE YOU HAVE
INCUMBENTS ON THE BALLOT AS WELL
AS ARIZONA AND NEVADA AND SO
THIS JUST HAS NOT BEEN TOP OF
MIND FOR THEM BUT ONE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OFFICIAL TELLING ME TODAY
AS YOU WERE JUST SAYING, NIA,
THAT THEY VIEW THIS AS A
REPUBLICAN STATE.
IT'S JUST A TOUGH SITUATION.
BUT THAT THEY DO SEE RYAN AS A
GOOD CANDIDATE WHO'S GIVING
VANCE A RUN FOR HIS MONEY.
>> ONE OF THE PROBLEMS, I THINK,
AND THE REASON YOU HEAR A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION IN THE RYAN CAMP IS
J.D. VANCE WAS STRUGGLING.
A LITTLE ON THE ROPES THEN YOU
SEE THE REPUBLICANS, MOSTLY
REALLY MITCH McCONNELL POURING
MONEY IN TO GIVE HIM A BIT OF A
MONEY ADVANTAGE, 15 MILLION ON
THE GOP SIDE TO JUST 5 MILLION
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE AND HE
WAS ON "MORNING JOE" THIS
MORNING TALKING ABOUT JUST THE
FACT THAT HE IS ALL BY HIS
LONESOME OVER IN OHIO.
LISTEN.
>> WE STILL CAN'T GET THE KIND
OF AIR SUPPORT THAT J.D. VANCE
IS GETTING BUT, LOOK, MAKE NO
MISTAKE, WE JUST HAD A HUGE
FUND-RAISING HAUL AND RAISED $17
MILLION, THE NATIONAL AND STATE
DONOR BASE ARE BEING VERY, VERY
HELPFUL.
YOU KNOW, LOW DOLLAR DONORS,
LIKE IT A LITTLE BIT THAT WE'RE
DAVID VERSUS GOLIATH BECAUSE
WE'LL SHOCK THE WORLD.
>> IT WOULD BE A SHOCK.
>> HE KIND OF DOESN'T LIKE --
>> LISTEN, MORE MONEY IS MORE
MONEY, YOU KNOW, IN A RACE THIS
CLOSE IN A STATE AS BIG AS OHIO.
IT'S A RED STATE, A RED YEAR
WHICH IS WHY DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING, LISTEN, LET'S FOCUS ON
NEVADA AND GEORGIA.
LET'S FOCUS ON A REACH STATE
LIKE MAYBE PENNSYLVANIA OR
WISCONSIN, RATHER THAN OHIO
WHICH HAS PROVEN TO BE A
HEARTBREAKING STATE FOR
DEMOCRAT.
>> HAD THEY THINK IT'S CLOSE
IT'S NOT THAT CLOSE.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE HOLDING BACK